salut ça y est on l'a fait on vient de
passer les 400000 c'est juste un truc de
ouf 400000 vous êtes 400 milles sur
cette chaîne merci pour commencer il ya
un an quasiment jour pour jour en était
en train de préparer la faq des 2500
abonnés pour fêter ses quatre cent mille
j'ai décidé de vous appeler c'est à dire
qu'en préparation de cette vidéo il ya
quelques temps sur facebook je vous ai
proposé
si vous étiez disponible de faire une
petite mentalisation via skype
plus de deux mille réponses plus tard et
bien c'est parti c'est ce matin que je
vais vous appeler pour essayer de vous
mentaliser on verra le nombre de fois où
je réussis et surtout à la fin de la
vidéo je vous explique quelle a été ma
méthodologie pour vous mentaliser merci
d'être ici et moi je vous mets 400000
pouce en l'air
bam
[Musique]
tu es le premier que j'appelle sur cette
série de vidéos
alors sauf que tu ne sais pas du tout
pourquoi j'appelle c'est ça et non je ne
sais pas l'idée pour la vidéo des 400
milles ces deux c'est d'essayer de
trouver à quoi pense une personne parmi
un choix limité sur un maximum de
personnes et à la fin de la vidéo je
vous expliquerai comment j'ai fait je
t'entends mais je ne te vois pas à carla
donc tu choisis une des huit images
celle qui te fait plaisir à toi tu en
choisit une dans ta tête tu regardes les
huit dessins et en choisit un dans ta
tête celui toutes les études me dit
quand tu es prêt donc tu choisis une
image parmi les huit images et tu me dis
ok je suis crème est en fait moi je vais
te poser deux à trois questions qui
répond que dans ta tête
c'est bon c'est bon tu vas jamais me
répondre verbalement sa marche par
exemple dans les images il ya elle se
différencie vraiment par deux types ya
celles qui ont des courbes et celles qui
n'en n'ont pas je te demander de
regarder la tienne est juste de regarder
dans ta tête s'il ya des courbes ou pas
dans ton dessin ok merci pour cette
réponse non verbale c'est est ce qu'il
ya des courbes dans ce dessin tu vois
d'un parce que suivant les dessins il y
avait des death un buisson plutôt
linéaire et des dessins plutôt avec des
courbes et vu comment tu as regardé par
trois fois je dirais que oui c'est court
mais de partout donc ça c'est chouette
par exemple où il est complètement
ouvert et des dessins qui sont fermés
genre le carré il est complètement
fermée du coup si c'est plus ouverts
c'est soit sur les vagues ce soit sur le
chrome et si je me plante complètement
c'est sur le cercle où le cerveau je
pense à arthon symbole il ya des images
qui nécessite quatre traits poète de
signer et d'autres qui nécessitent trois
ou moins je vois par exemple le carré cé
carré l'étoile c'est sacré
ces trois traits lacroix ces deux traits
etc etc c'est une mini mentalisation des
familles rapide
je veux au culot à si je rate je rate et
je garde quand même le rush je mettrai
dans le médoc j'ai raté on va voir un
pourcentage est ce que tu peux me dire
exactement à quel dessein qui pensaient
aussi n'y pige au sigle pays oui on est
bon merci monsieur maxime plusieurs
indices et quand je fais ça ça marche
bien du coup jeu direct et sur le cercle
c'est ça oui
et du coup jeu direct et sur les trois
vagues comme ça c'est ça ouais
oui je dirais pour l'instant j'ai fait
un sans faute depuis ce matin mais là
j'ai un petit doute sur toi je dirais
que c'est le home l'espèce de symboles
comme 1 3 avec une vague derrière rouen
ce soir c'est ça oui je te sais que
l'écran mais j'étais tchèque mais je
pense être certain d'une chose je pense
que tu as choisi quelque chose avec des
lignes très droite mais j'hésite entre
l'étoile et qui j'ai direct a choisi le
symbole de pièces que j'ai bon bah oui
j'ai chaud qu'à 90% sur tu as choisi le
cercle est ce que c'est correct
non c'est mon premier fait il de la
journée c'était quoi à le home page été
bon sur les à la condi mais c'était
ouvert et un jeu aussi
écoute je suis désolé pour toi et c'est
pas la connexion c'est juste moi qui me
suis planté tu es le premier à d'après
simon c'était adorable et j'ai
l'impression qu'ils étaient sur les
symboles du home
c'est bon vous passez sort de trois avec
exactement j'étais décidé tout de suite
c'est
c'est cette espèce de truc là comme ça
c'est ça oui on s'arrête à cet appel
parce que la période là pour eux que
j'ai pour tourner est terminée j'ai beau
y profère les tirages au sort j'ai à peu
près 40 demandes de de message bougez
pas de réponse donc j'ai demandé à tout
le monde si vous étiez disponibles et le
pire c'est julien audy et gaëtan rohner
maxi boullier etienne larrouy dommages à
caïn mathieu marché ça en fait c'est que
les mecs qui me répondent pas du coup je
la vois une vidéo qu avec des meufs et
on va se dire ouais comme par hasard
merci en tout cas à tous ceux qui ont
participé
c'est cool et pour la méthode que j'ai
utilisé je voulais explique j'ai créé un
effet tunnel sur huit images ces huit
images là je sais qu'en trois questions
je peux trouver quelle image a
sélectionné la personne la première
question c'est est-ce que le dessin à
des courbes ou uniquement des très droit
et si vous regardez bien il ya quatre
dessins avec des courbes et quatre
dessins avec des traits droit une fois
que je sais cette information soit
verbalement soit là en l'occurrence pour
les vidéos non verbalement je vais
encore re divisée en deux par exemple
s'ils allaient courbe je vais essayer de
savoir si le dessin est fermé comme le
cercle par exemple ouvert comme le home
s'il ya juste des traits droit je vais
essayer de savoir s'il ya 4 et ou moins
que 4 et exemple dans pi a trois très
m'étendre le carré il ya quatre traits
et là encore une fois il me reste plus
que deux possibilités c'est à dire que
sur mes limites de départ j'arrive pour
ma dernière question un choix final
entre soi au mais les vagues soit le
cercle ou cerveau soit la croix ou pis
soit les toiles ou le carré et c'est un
vrai truc là que je vous donne pour vous
entraîner à faire du mentalisme de vous
pouvez reprendre exactement mes dessins
et vous vous entraînez et à chaque fois
vous faites valider sa verbalement par
la personne dit par exemple je pense que
c'est que de sauter sur une courbe comme
ça si elle dit non vous pouvez toujours
pour attraper continuer si elle dit oui
ça vous permet d'avancer
et vous savez dans trois questions vous
aurez le dessin au final c'est un
excellent entraînement j'espère que ce
petit cadeau des quatre cent mille
abonnés vous plaira merci tellement
d'être là moi je vais vous voir bientôt
sur les dates de tournée elle c'est un
vrai clip de vous voir à chaque fois à
la fin là je vais être en spectacle à
grenoble après je vais être en spectacle
à lyon
nice est peut-être je dis bien peut-être
je suis en train d'essayer de faire un
événement à nantes pour réunir des
bretons qui voudront bien faire le
déplacement et la zone danthez même ceux
de charente maritime qui voudraient
venir
donc on est en train de voir ça dites
moi d'ailleurs dans les commentaires si
si vous seriez capable de vous déplacer
en nombre pour venir
auquel cas je prendrai peut-être le
risque d'organiser cet événement bon
quoi qu'il en soit merci d'être 400
mille mercis c'est donc c'est ouf c'est
pour une fois c'est moi qui vous met le
pouce en l'air
à très bientôt charm